[Applaudissements]
mais 7 février 2000 j'ai été victime
d'un accident de ski
enfin victime c'est pas moi qui le dis
parce que en fait c'était un grand
concours de testostérone l'imaginer je
suis là avoriaz avec mon grand frère mon
petit frère mon cousin mes meilleurs
potes et ça fait depuis qu'on a quatre
cinq ans qu'on se tire la bourre à ce
qui ce qu'il plus vite a su qui saute le
plus haut mais cette année là je me sens
bien je me sens conquérant je fais des
super saut est donc là on décide d'aller
skier d'après-midi juste entre jeunes
nos parents nous détendre nous attendent
ce qui n'est pas très beau et comme il
fait pas bon se réfugier dans un parc de
surf
donc évidemment à l'entrée du parc de
surf du surf pardon il ya écrit
exclusivement réservé aux surfeurs ça
tombe bien nous sommes skieurs et on
fait des sauts et puis et puis on se
rapproche du de leurs deux rendez-vous
on devait tous aller au cinéma vers 17h
puis mon grand frère nous déballer les
gars dernier saut je m'élance d'abord
puis avec ben notre petit frère et maxi
notre cousin et puis cette année michael
vous finissez puisqu'en plus s'avère que
c'est nous les plus plus barjots de la
bande les meilleurs sauteurs donc voilà
le destin nous départager de savoir en
car enfin qui a le plus de testostérone
moi j'étais persuadé que c'était moi
d'ailleurs je suis toujours persuadé que
c'est moi et à ce moment là ben le fond
leur sceau des petits sauts de cabri et
puis nous attendent en bas de la bosse
et stan s'élance il ya trois sauts à la
suite des big air pour ceux qui sont un
petit peu rider céder sous qui monte à
la verticale vous descendez comme ça
vous monte à la verticale fait une
figure il ya un petit plat sur le haut
de la bosse et vous atterrissez dans la
descente
c'est à ne s'élance premier saut très
beaux sauts compact deuxième saut il
freine un peu entre les deux bosses aux
compacts puis troisième finale et là
vraiment le type ut un ballet de la
testostérone et puis à mon tour et là je
sais ils sont tous derrière ils
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est que je
m'éclate
notamment parce qu'il ya mes frères et
mes cousins et qui sont plus proches de
moi que mes potes ma famille d'abord et
donc là c'est voilà moi je m'élance je
pousse sur mes bâtons fait ce premier
saut bosso compact puis deuxième saut
mais moi je vais le battre aujourd'hui
donc je freine pas entre les deux sauts
et donc j'y arrive très vite et
l'achever le 2e saut je me rétablis je
monte à 4,5 mètres c'est déjà assez haut
mais je me rétablis méchant que je suis
en train de perdre un peu l'équilibré
et puis là ça se passe en une
microseconde je me retrouve face à un
mur le troisième saut et vous savez vous
avez tous fait j'imagine des salles et
des montagnes russes des grands 8
ce n'est pas tant la descente qui est
flippante ces moments où ça remonte
cette sensation comme un train qui vont
rentrer dans le ventre en fait c'est ce
qui s'est passé à ce moment là j'ai pas
freiner le bon sens aurait voulu que je
ferai demain sauvage mais si c'est pour
moi c'est mon jour je vais les battre je
vais le battre et leur montrer à quel
point c'est moi le plus fort du haut de
mes 18 ans lui à 21 ans mon grand frère
à 20 ans j'ai envie de trouver j'ai une
maman sip et déjà ils m'ont volé
beaucoup je me suis envolé je suis monté
à 8 10 mètres de hauteur et là des
leçons mon grand frère a commencé à
courir à sprinter parce qu'il a vu qu'il
y avait un espèce de pantin désarticulé
j'ai perdu connaissance au moment où je
me suis envolé et au lieu d'atterrir
tranquillement dans la descente je
tombais à côté de la bosse sur une
plaque de verglas à 8 10 mètres de
hauteur et donc à ce moment là j'ai été
emmené tout de suite au poste de secours
d'avoriaz ceux là ont skié ils ont fait
le premier radio et donc fracture du
fémur droit double fracture du fémur
gauche mais surtout fracture de la
colonne vertébrale la 11e et la 12e
dorsale là je suis emmené à l'hôpital de
genève qui est l'hôpital le plus proche
et donc son père qu'elle veut dire une
opération qui dure 9 heures où l'armée
mais des plaques et des vis dans les
jambes et dans le dos
deux jours plus tard moi je suis
toujours dans le coltard imaginé ces
quatre jours où j'étais conscient mais
vous venez aucun souvenir ce que je vous
raconte c'est ce que m'ont rappelé et
mes proches voilà ce que ont vécu à
travers moi deux jours plus tard en soin
intensif ce que j'étais en soins
intensifs a peut-être commencé ce
parcours de de réaux de reconstruction
pas de rééducation encore mais de
reconstruction collective que quand vous
êtes victime d'un accident de la vie pas
uniquement la personne qui a eu
l'accident qui est victime
c'est tout votre entourage et tous les
ans qui tous les gens qui vous aiment
j'avais au moins ma famille ancrée qui
met mais à l'époque je me suis rendu
compte qu'il ya quelques personnes qui
mouille pas trop en tout cas ma famille
mes mais est plutôt beaucoup et bout de
deux jours chez en soins intensifs
imaginer je suis allongé comme ça dans
un endroit il ya des gens qui sont en
train de mourir c'est extrêmement
violent commandant tel le christ allongé
comme ça avec des tubes un peu partout
et donc imaginer alors oubliez tout ce
que vous avez consommé dans votre
adolescence où ce que consomme est
d'ailleurs actuellement parce que
j'étais encore tous très jeunes
la morphine c'est le top du top j'étais
défoncé à la morphine et donc à ce
moment là bas je plane réellement et
donc arrive mes parents m'ont quatre
maisons que les tantes mes frères mes
cousins et là je me lance dans une
imitation alors vous êtes peut-être un
peu jeunes pour la plupart d'entre vous
mais je vous conseille la trilogie du
parrain et marlon brando dans le parrain
c'est lui qui parle un peu comme ça et
en fait moi je pars dans une imitation
comme ça donc j'appelle mon frère tu vas
aller détruire la brosse directeur de la
station je suis comme ça ça fait 48
heures que je suis allongé que je suis
paralysé des membres inférieurs parce
que les fractures à la colonne
vertébrale a entraîné chez moi une
paraplégie et donc à ce moment là il ya
un fou rire et c'est qu'avec un peu de
recul que quelques mois après je me sens
du compte c'était le point de départ de
cette reconstruction collective
je rentre à paris quelques semaines à
l'hôpital très durs très très dur parce
qu'en fait là le corps d'un adulte
les dix huit ans presque d'un adulte et
et surtout bien l'autonomie d'un enfant
d'un an
donc j'avais pas m'habiller tout seul je
n'ai pas à me laver je n'ai pas fermé
besoin je n'avais pas mangé je vais pas
me laver les dents je pouvais rien faire
tout seul donc c'est une situation
extrêmement compliquée dans la vie d'un
homme une femme bien sûr de se retrouver
dans une situation de dépendance
et puis c'est de l' angoisse à quoi ça
ressemble la vie d'un mec en fauteuil
moi j'ai 18 ans j'ai jamais vue du
handicap et ça fait 17 ans que j'ai eu
mon accident à l'époque moi j'en voyais
jamais on n'a pas beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui et donc qu'il attend avec
impatience la près la presse et le
centre de rééducation donc star pendant
neuf mois en cendres ducation et là en
fait c'est un sentiment particulier si
vous attendez que ce soit des moments
difficiles extrêmement difficile et en
fait pour moi ça a été des moments
extraordinaires
imaginez vous avez un joker de neuf mois
enfin joe cole de neuf mois et donc
pendant neuf mois faites ce que vous
voulez enfin il ya un cadre
effectivement c'est une prison dorée
vous n'avez pas le droit de partir le
week-end sur deux lots sans autorisation
vous avez le réveil matin le coucher à
telle ou telle heure mais et toute la
journée vous avez un espèce de joker
c'est à dire que moi j'avais un voisin
de chambre tétraplégique qui pouvaient
pas rouler ses joies et m'a appris à
rouler s'est joint à lui couper son shit
avant de son shit ces deals pour que moi
je puisse fumer gratuitement
alors c'est parti dans l'éducation les
douleurs neurologiques évidemment on
avait besoin de fumer et beaucoup mais à
ce moment là qui va vous dire à ce
moment à vous dis c'est pas bien ce que
vous faites arrêter de fumer
non laissez nous tranquilles on a besoin
de passer par ça c'est mes temps que
j'ai perdu vingt kilos donc je faisais
que bouffer mais bouffé le truc qui nous
équiper en même si la cantine pas
extraordinaire mais mais simplement je
faisais ce que je voulais et puis
surtout je me suis rendu compte mais
qu'est ce qui me fait le plus peur
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est dans un
fauteuil roulant
en fait non à 18 ans et je crois pas que
j'étais plus obsédé que vous tous dans
la salle c'était en fait de plaire
est-ce que je vais père est ce que je
vais pouvoir séduire est ce qu'on va
avoir envie de me séduire est ce qu'on a
envie de faire l'amour avec moi est ce
qu'on va vouloir mais mais par l'amour
c'est venu plus tard je me posais pas
avancer question c'était beaucoup plus
primaires que ça à ce moment là et donc
je me suis dit bon bah on va on va se
lancer on va on va sortir de cette zone
de confort où on est materner notamment
par le service par les soignants et donc
ça a été une espèce de quête frénétique
où je suis sorti avec régis sortie c'est
la façon propre de dire que voilà j'ai
baisé la terre entière mais je me suis
baiser je me suis fait baiser j'ai baisé
la terre entière ce qui veut dire c'est
qu'à ce moment là j'avais besoin de
conquérir le monde j'avais besoin de
vous prouver à tous une personne
handicapée ce n'est pas forcément une
personne asexué que c'est une personne
qui peut désirer c'est une personne qui
peut vous faire plaisir c'est une
personne qui vous pouvez me donner du
plaisir et pour moi c'est un des plus
grands tabous donc je me suis
reconstruit comme ça pendant de nombreux
et nombreux mois nombreuses années ça
toute ma vie entre temps je construis
d'autres choses et puis il a fallu
sortir de ce centre de rééducation quand
je sortis du centre de rééducation
la première fois que je sortis c'est mon
grand frère qui m'a forcé j'avais pas
envie je n'ai pas eu à me confronter à
vous vous validez vous societe
discriminant thorpe à vous
personnellement mais la société
discriminant que vis-à-vis des personnes
handicapées et donc il m'a emmené on est
sorti dans notre quartier est à peine 50
mètres passait il ya une dame qui me
regardent et elle me regarde avec un
regard rempli de toute la misère du
monde de pitié de compassion cesse
regarde et on se croisait le contient me
regarder comme ça à l'époque la jetez
pas encore autonome mon frère me pousser
et là bizarrement j'ai été pris d'un
élan d'autonomie j'ai poussé mon côté je
les rattrape et j'ai attrapé le bras
très fort et j'ai hurlé dessus mais on
les tue parce que j'étais triste si je
me sentais agresser je trouve ça
extrêmement violent je me sens à la vie
que je vais avoir c'est ça l'image que
je renvoie alors que j'ai pas avoir
l'impression de me renvoyer sa muse et
mon frère qui se retrouve avec une dame
d'une quarantaine d'années en train
d'hurler
parce qu'un mec en fauteuil est en train
de lui faire mal aux bras laissez-moi au
secours au secours et moi je suis là et
je suis comme un fou
bon bref ça s'est bien terminé elle est
partie en pleurant et donc à ce moment
là à ce moment là je savais que ça
allait être compliqué et le sport le
sport mais normaux et des gîtes et
ancien joueur de tennis et je suis
devenu assez rapidement joueurs du
tennis en fauteuil professionnel j'ai
une ascension extrêmement rapide j'ai
été en 2004 médailles aux jeux d'athènes
dont 93 un accident j'ai eu le bronze et
l'argent en 2005 j'étais numéro mondial
en simple et en double et puis en 2008
ça a été la consécration j'ai eu ma
première médaille d'or aux jo de pékin
en double et pendant toute cette période
là et bien en fait je me suis rendu
compte qu'en voyageant à travers le
monde que j'étais un de
privilégiés mais pas uniquement au sein
de la minorité à laquelle j'appartiens
au sein de vous tous au sein de
l'humanité la liberté d'avoir accès à
tout ce que j'ai envie d'avoir accès à
tout ce dont j'ai besoin
tout ce qui me rend heureux parce que
finalement de quoi on parle parle de
bonheur c'est quoi la vie c'est ça sert
que qu'est ce qui vous motive au
quotidien d'entreprendre puisque vous
faites assez d'être heureux en tout cas
moi ce qui m'anime c'est comment je vais
m'éclater aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui va
faire que je vais être le plus heureux
possible alors je me dis pas comme ça
devant mon miroir tous les matins mais
c'est ça l'enjeu est donc je me suis
rendu compte de ça et un an avant les
jeux de londres je me suis dit
mais en fait qu'est-ce que je peux faire
concrètement et donc avec mon grand
frère et ma femme parce que oui j'ai une
femme j'ai cofondé l'association comme
les autres une association qui s'est
spécialisé dans l'accompagnement pour
personnes handicapées comme moi victime
d'un accident de la vie dans leur
parcours de construction en gros l'idée
c'est tout ce qu'on a vécu ensemble pas
pourquoi on ne ferait pas au service des
autres leur donner une boîte à outils
qui leur permet tout simplement un jour
d'accéder dorée accéder au bonheur comme
moi j'ai eu la chance de le vivre et
donc c'est une association qui se
développe qui me rend extrêmement
heureux parce que je suis quelqu'un
d'engagé mais pour des causes d'intérêt
général
et c'est extrêmement épanouissant et ce
qui se passe c'est que bat depuis
maintenant six ans cette association se
développe
et puis moi j'ai pris une décision
c'était pour quelques mois après cette
très belle photo où j'ai eu la chance
d'être le porte drapeau aux derniers
jeux paralympiques
je suis persuadé que vous avez tous
suivi assidûment
vous étiez parmi les 14 millions de
personnes qui nous ont suivis et
encouragés et en fait je me suis dit
voilà c'est ça termine de la plus belle
des manières une vraie reconnaissance de
mes pairs pour mes résultats mais
surtout pour mes engagements pour mes
prises de paroles pour ma liberté de ton
et et pour tout ce que j'entreprends
depuis pas mal d'années mais finalement
tout ça c'est bien
on parle de sport de haut niveau on
parle d'entrepreneuriat social j'avais
monté aussi une société à quelques
années on parle d'association
j'ai beaucoup de lobbying médiatique et
politique pour tout simplement des gens
comme moi ne soient plus des citoyens de
seconde zone
qu'on ait les mêmes droits et non pas
uniquement les mêmes devoirs ce qu'un
vrai enjeu aujourd'hui et tout ça voilà
me portent au quotidien il ya quelque
chose en fait qui est essentielle dans
mon parcours c'est que depuis que suis
tout petit j'ai toujours voulu fonder
une famille marc excuse parce que je
veux simplement reproduire l'image
l'image du foyer que j'avais à la maison
que j'ai toujours d'ailleurs mes parents
et mes frères mais en tout cas c'est
toujours quelque chose qui m'a dit mais
pendant cette fête frénétique de
conquérir la terre entière
eh bien eh ben je disais mais en fait
l'amour c'est pas pour moi et puis un
jour ça m'est tombé dessus
une belle kiné qui travaillait pour
l'ennemi stella kiné de l'équipe
anglaise est sortis ensemble et puis on
s'est marié en 2012 puis pendant
plusieurs années ça n'a pas été simple
mais on a vécu peut-être ce que ce que
fait d'être porte drapeau d'avoir eu
quatre médailles paralympiques
vous êtes quelque chose de bien plus
intense que ça a quelque chose de bien
plus fort c'est que j'ai eu la chance le
11 mars 2016 de devenir papa papa d'un
petit milow par vous aurez compris un
maillot moi je voulais qu'ils
s'appellent lyon mais comme jeune femme
anglaise à la gagner c'est le 14 tel
bébé et j'ai vécu l'émotion la plus
violente de mon existence
et y'a rien qui aujourd'hui me rend plus
fier de mon parcours
parce que je vais pouvoir le transmettre
à ce petit bonhomme parce que j'espère
qu'un jour ils me regardent et qui va
être fier de moi fier de ce que j'ai
accompli et et notamment parce que
l'engagement d'engagement il est
essentiel dans votre construction
d'êtres humains dans 30 ou construction
de citoyens le sentiment d'utilité c'est
ce qui vous rendra profondément heureux
et moi si j'ai eu la chance de vivre ce
parcours qui est extraordinaire pas au
sens meilleur que vous mais pas
ordinaire
c'est peut-être tout simplement comme le
dit si bien brice ionique simplement le
fait que j'ai été victime le 7 février
2000 d'un merveilleux malheur
merci
[Applaudissements]